this is something that that i believe
you
were very interested in talking more
about um and here it is let's talk about
bill gates and what's going on with him
he says i believe he's on page eight
he says bill gates rich nation should
move to 100
synthetic beef bill gates recently said
that he believes rich nations
should would help the global fight
against climate change
by consuming only plant-based 100
synthetic meat products instead of beef
you can get used to the taste difference
and the claim is they're going to make
it taste even better over time
says gates the philanthropist and
microsoft
co-founder said that he is hopeful that
a turn to plant-based proteins will
combat
methane emissions produced by livestock
even gates recognize that this idea is
hard to swallow
saying that people you can't have cows
anymore saying to people you can't have
cows anymore
talk about talk about a politically
unpopular approach
to things however the global hunger for
plant-based foods continues to grow
here's some numbers for you morningstar
forecast that the plant-based meat
market will reach
74 billion by 2029 the end of the decade
up from currently 12 billion that was in
2019
and beyond meat is working with
mcdonald's and fast food chains like
taco bell and kfc
to roll out plant-based sandwiches and
other alternative meat items
this year is that the end of this story
kai yep
okay this is some this is i mean is this
a hundred percent that's what he's
saying what do you think about it here's
what i think about it bill gates needs a
side hustle
he needs something else to do other than
come up with these wild stupid things
that he does
three times a week uh he's too bored
you know he's got a side 100 he's got
he's he's he's been talking about
vaccines well then hustle more on that
and and keep beef out of it okay warren
buffett is good friends
with bill gates right i think they're
the best of friends do you know that
there's
seven million cows in nebraska and
there's 1.8 million
people in nebraska do you know how big
the beef industry is
in nebraska in this country i mean are
you on i mean for him to throw something
out that i mean it's almost like
i think it does bill gates legacy a
little hard because he almost comes
across as a crackpot now there might be
some
scientific thing that he could spin and
and you know in
387 years down the road if we did this
it would benefit
but no one's going to buy this right now
or or have you ever tried
fake beef i've had a beyonce have i and
they're okay i mean it takes like a bad
turkey burger if you ask me
you know beyond meat it's okay i mean
and i think they're gonna be improving
it constantly
but how can you make a statement like
this when when that industry is so big
it affects so many jobs and so many
livelihoods
maybe it just seems when i see a bill
gates headline now i'm going
how crazy can i think that just when you
see a bill gates
headline is it like instant
non-credibility at this point
i don't know bill gates is you know who
he is so you know his accomplishments
speak for themselves but
how are you going to get america to go
100 fake beef that
will not happen you will have a lot of
americans moving to poor countries
okay because he's saying all rich
countries should get rid of beef and
just have fake beef well a lot of
americans would be leaving this country
well i mean listen according to the
numbers here we go right morning star
forecast that the plant-based meat
market will reach 74 billion by 2029
up from currently 12 billion that was
last year i say that's a small number
i'd say 74 will be higher than that it's
it's big and they're going to improve it
every single year
it's going to get better and better and
better but i just i just don't think
we're there yet where americans can wrap
their arms
i think the problem that we're having
right now is the fact that i mean this
is why we're talking about
because if he said rich nation should
move to 40
synthetic beef we would we wouldn't even
be questioning this we'd be like all
right cool like
have more you know synthetic beef
whatever the health synthetic beef is
you know fake meat or whatever
um but the fact that he's saying a
hundred percent
again headlines is the people like what
what do you mean i can't have a freaking
hamburger eric lever
every day for lunch he has a hamburger
every day it's crazy
we know what your number one uh thing
that you like to eat is but
um burgers is at the top of the list
yeah i went there
now uh would you eat fake meat
absolutely not you would not no that's
my point you're gonna get a lot you just
wouldn't if we said 100 fake beef you're
not even gonna have a bite of that no i
want my meat no
and there's two oh i'm a meat steak
people there's too many people like that
so yeah i mean you go to texas right now
you're going to tell some dude in texas
driving around in his truck hanging out
with
it'll be like prohibition it'll be a
huge underground black market for
damn the underground beef market
or the mafia is going to get involved
and it's going to become a bigger
business than it is now because it's
going to go underground i mean
there's there's history has shown time
time again that's how it works guys give
me something different give me a
different perspective i know you love
hamburgers you're from norway though so
there's
what do you got here's a prediction oh
what you got we have the
the gasoline industry or the gas for car
gas cars versus electrical vehicles yes
i think in the future you're going to
see a push
towards you know how we're pushing
towards electrical vehicles it's going
to be a push
towards more plant-based beef
and a lower decrease on beef i don't
think it's gonna go
a hundred percent overnight that's not
yeah we have air glares in the world
a lot of them what's this what's his
point on the point the point on the
admissions
is essentially if you're playing if
you're um if you're planting right so
to create a cow you need you need uh you
need a lot of acres for food
and they need to eat and 90 essentially
if you think of it roughly 90 of the
food that a cow eats goes to just
maintenance right 10 percent goes to
growth so if you
they need to eat a lot of food in order
to gain
a lot of weight right so say they're 100
pounds then they need a thousand pounds
of food which that food could be better
used if you go if you go
directly to grain and or they create
fake fake beef out of it
so there's a lot of inefficiencies with
beet and raising
animals because they need to eat a lot
just to maintain or to grow and get
bigger
so that's where he's saying the
admission comes out that it's more
pollution
for sustaining animals than to let just
eat the grass or the the plant base that
you could
be planting on the same area let me pick
up where you were where you went by the
way well done you're going predictions i
mean he's drawing diagrams venn diagrams
that makes sense good job yeah so that's
that's his argument that we're
he's saying that we're a first world
nation that we can afford that
and we can um make more use out of the
land that we're on
so that's kind of where he's going with
the admissions of the methane that
cows produce and then also just the
general stuff around it now
how realistic is it to transition from
one to the other i don't know
but uh i one thing i suggest is we do a
blind meat test where
i see an episode there can we get can we
put that on an idea yeah
a a a a taste a taste test yeah i i i
want to see
here's the idea not be able to
spot the difference between i would love
and real meat i would love that i would
love to go
beyond meat i would love to you know be
a connoisseur of beyond me because the
health benefits alone i would yeah i
would be ecstatic if i were to
you know the nba players have really
helped push beyond me they're based in
el segundo
which is the next city over from where i
live and they really they really are
blowing up could you imagine if
elon musk had come out and said we
should be 100
fake beef could you imagine that would
have done it would
yeah but you know what i just it's
unfair to pick on one industry when you
have as much influence as you do as bill
gates and i and
if i was in that industry where i could
be really truly harmed
i would be really resentful for him to
say something like that i think it would
be more responsible to say hey look
the benefits outweigh you know having
this much beef consumption and here's
why let me tell you and you know this
country's capable of maybe getting there
i think it'll be
it'll prolong life it'll cut down
cardiovascular disease and heart disease
but he comes out with this 100 and that
just scares everybody
and it completely dilutes his point and
now you're not going to believe him
you're not you're going to be
anti-this whatever he says about it i
think i got
i disagree with you and i'll tell you
why like i said if he said hey we should
eat more synthetic beef and that's all
he said and just kind of left it just
you know hey
do you do what you want we wouldn't even
be talking about this story right now
the fact that he
listen agree with bill gates or don't
agree with bill gates the guy
is a genius and he knows what he's doing
if he comes out there and says
rich nation should move to a hundred
percent synthetic beef he knows that
that's gonna be a headline
like you know thinking of headlines here
you write the headlines for vt post
you know that's clickbait materials
exactly what we're doing right now we're
talking about this
topic talking about your predictions
listen
things were trending in a different
direction in america and in the world
for everything but what i think happened
is the pandemic you know mate
exacerbated a million different types of
changes to say hold on what's going on
here
you talked about the electric car
vehicles versus gasoline and oil power
you know clearly there's some green
changes going on with that
clearly this beef topic that we're
talking about right there i can't tell
you how many calls i'm getting from
people
bitcoin bitcoin bitcoin bitcoin so you
got the bitcoin you got the ethereum you
get the crypto like
you know clearly people are making a
move in that direction obviously
zoom you know you know you're not
traveling for meetings talking about
emissions and bill gates
says he's one of the you know flying
private planes and doing all that he
gives off more emissions than anybody um
things have changed and i think
this is kind of to your prediction this
is something that we're gonna have you
ever even
thought about not eating a normal burger
less than five years someone said oh you
can have a veggie patty or a burger
five years ago it wasn't even a freaking
question i've now i'm like yeah
it's it's been proven you shouldn't eat
more red meat more than once a week
right now wink wink at ucla eating
swallow hamburgers a day
think about the first um cell phones
right and how far we've come with that
i think it can be the same thing talked
about blackberry and iphone something
like that
exactly have you ever had anybody tried
the sausage that beyond meat makes is
that any better i i
this guy eats it every day this guy eats
it literally every
day so recently what do you eat every
day for lunch chorizo
it has changed my life really it it
because you can't eat
regular chorizo every day you'll die but
ceriso
gives you that opportunity to have that
amazing chorizo flavor
uh but healthy interesting this podcast
is brought to you by
rito hey it gives you if you're gonna
eat uh regular chorizo you will die
and i really wanna like it i really do i
would love to fail that taste test
because i would be all in
i really would and i think they will
have i mean you're a cali boy this this
must be like all over the streets of l.a
yeah i mean how do you must have million
friends that are going vegan
and doing all that kind of stuff no yeah
but it's already happened right i mean
that's already just organically kind of
no one's making a big announcement that
hey i'm going this already happened in
california
bill last point on this from me bill
gates better hate steak
because if he's ever caught in a
steakhouse right now people are going to
take pictures of this hypocrite
and they're going to be sending it
everywhere so he better not eat a burger
in public when you come out with a
statement like this
is it me i i think
bill gates like i'm on the side if bill
gates says something
automatically i'm thinking bill gates
knows what he's doing
he knows what he's talking about i think
he like kind of you said like i don't
know he needs to kind of have a side
hustle or stick to his day job
i kind of think he's that smart and that
informed that he kind of knows what he's
talking about
my question to you is when you hear bill
gates say something do you have
like the oh he's a fake news kind of a
guy like i had that problem with trump
no doubt
if he said it i was like i don't know
here's my problem with him and
to your point here it's not that i doubt
his his brilliance i mean clearly the
guy's a genius i just question his
motives and that's the one thing when i
hear him agenda
if what he's saying does it benefit him
somehow down the road and
and whatever's happened with him in the
past has kind of created that for me
where that is
more or less the first thing i think of
when he says that is this benefiting him
his foundation or something more
that to the detriment of how it would
affect yeah maybe this is just me being
naive i'm too sure that's a perfect
segue to some comments right there
but i don't think he does it for his
money or to improve his
like i just think he generally cares i
think the jury's out on that
to be honest jury's out do you trust
bill gates like just trust him as a
human being like trust his instincts
or do you think he's kind of like a
selfish looking out for himself like
where are you at with no
i think more stuff he could be doing if
he wanted to further his
hidden political agenda in that sense uh
the guy's been top five richest guy in
the world for the last 20 years i think
he is a believer of what he's doing now
obviously does everyone agree
most likely not uh but i do think that
he especially with kind of
with his views on climate change and the
things that need to be done in order to
reach the goals
um i think that he's kind of in tune
with those and
i can see where he's coming from you you
trust bill gates instincts paul
um you trust bill gates i'm gonna say no
uh you do not trust me
he says something right away i'm not
gonna just blindly incline only
because i've heard enough red flag
stories
okay in the last 10 years about him uh
that that's my question
i'd love to hear the audience just trust
or mistrust of bill gates do you trust
him
or do you not trust him eric where are
you at with this trust or mistrust
i don't trust him and there's no like
solid debt i can give you yeah
i just he gives me a vibe i just can't
trust him so the the there's he doesn't
have the trust factor for you
interesting mario do you trust bill
gates no so i have an opinion on this i
think that sometimes like saying
someone's name we get a little emotional
right so as i'm listening i'm like man
everybody's so emotional about bill
gates i'm not crying you're crying
i'm not crying um but i think that when
it comes to something like this what i
take out of it is
how anything extreme is always going to
rub us the wrong way
but if we are naive to believe that we
can't get there
then we're very naive everybody both
sides middle i don't care because
if you would have told me a few months
ago that everywhere you freaking go
you're going to put on a mask
even when you're walking in an office
and when you're going to the restroom
when you yeah and then you feel guilty
for not wearing if you would have told
me that would have been society today
yeah where you look at a chick you look
at a dude you're looking at people
you're looking in business meetings
and then you're doing interviews
recently i was like i prefer to keep a
mask on i'm going to wear my mask
and you should be all personal if you
would have told that to me yeah
six months ago i would have said hell no
that's extreme
100 of people won't do it so when i hear
100
today here's what i take from this is we
cannot be naive
for me anything at an extreme
is too much so yes i agree with you adam
where if you say if he would have said
look we can gradually increase
and start moving into a little bit more
plant-based that was my point by the way
right tom thank you and i agree with tom
not with adam i never agree with adam
unless about what we're gonna eat
so the other part is beef baby the other
part is
that um i i also trust the science if
there are facts that are leading and i
just looked up an article here while you
guys were talking but
science does say that methane emissions
are increasing so what the hell are we
doing about it
you know it's really good for me i'm 33
but what about you know and i do think
about what about the youth what about
society what about the environment
like we're kind of effed up you know to
not care about those things
because we do need some longevity what
freaking planet are we going to live on
so i think that is important as well but
anytime we go extreme i think that's the
case
um but the other part i think regulation
is very important too
when we interviewed if you go back and
you watch if you haven't watched it
already go watch the interview with chad
sullivan
but talk you know he talks a direct
impact about the meat industry
go watch that interview and understand a
little bit more about the whole
aspect of being a business owner and
what they had to go through dealing with
covenant regulating where meat was
coming from at that point
because if you understand the world that
they're in you can't just put them out
of business either you have no idea who
you're affecting
so if regulation is included i mean meat
could gradually get better if you
process it better because look if you're
gonna pick right now and i'm reading the
comments but
are you gonna go to burger king you're
going to go to mcdonald's you're going
to go to shake shack are you going to go
to in and out are you going to go
where are you going to go to a
restaurant like a down here chop steak
house and you're going to go ask for a
burger where do you get your meat from
so i hate to go long-winded on this but
i think look if you're extreme about it
you're going to get a lot of hate if
you're naive about it don't forget what
happened with mass you're probably going
to put one on right after the podcast
wherever you go
and then from there we need to improve
regulation but we can't be emotional
when it comes to
an individual and their name or whatever
they did on their past
because if you're perfect then i mean
you should be the one commenting
i mean walking on water great great
great insight by the legendary
i'd also be curious to know how much of
because obviously if you have like
organically plant-raised meat which is
like the non-processed
the straight cows just coming right off
the farm that
healthy meat the the high quality meat
right
but then you also have all the like
crappy meat which is a lot of like the
mcdonald's meat and a lot of just ground
stuff and
the the stuff what paul used to eat
before he went to the store
and and and that percentage i'd be
curious of like how much is
the good quality meat and how much of
the meat out there is just kind of the
stuff that
they're force-feeding the cows so that
they get gain weight
there's a documentary there as soon as
possible because that meat can't be too
healthy either and that's where i
think that a lot of that could be moved
more towards a plant-based meat
and that would also help environment i
think i think the point is
things have changed right things have
changed whether it's
electric vehicles whether it's bitcoin
whether it's
um synthetic meat we're open to new
things now to say no and we're never
doing i'm never doing this
like our friend galera said i would
never like maybe you're going to
consider that now i don't know
you won't do the taste i look forward to
this taste test yes
okay that's what and just last point
about bill gates this is why i kind of
find
the instant credit i won't say instant
credibility this is why i trust him
pull up something called the billionaire
pledge pull up something called a
billion are you guys familiar with this
is billionaire pledge you know about
this
okay basically this is what he started
with what the gates found bill and
melinda gates foundation he's basically
saying listen guys
we've had the luxury of living in
america here making billions
right he's a capitalist right he's a
democratic capitalist you can be both
um wait wait wait should i agree to the
privacy notice here or no
let me know if i should agree or not
agree i'm not sure anymore this is about
building
this is about building on a wonderful
tradition of philanthropy stop mario
that will ultimately help the world
become a much better place that is the
number one quote
on that on that on his site um to me
if you're a billionaire and you're
basically saying i think what's the
number they're going to pledge
90 50 is it more than 50. i think he's
i think some of these people are
pledging 90 of their wealth if you're
worth a hundred billion dollars and you
give you know
90 billion dollars to charity of your
choice
um that's pretty impressive man that to
me
gets you some instant credibility no but
you don't trust bill gates
anyway if you if you want to check that
out uh
billionaire pledge bill gates the giving
pledge that's what it's called
the giving place it certainly puts
pressure on other billionaires doesn't
it 100 percent of them
hey zuck did you do it yeah i did hey uh
musk did you do it yeah
a lot of them uh that or i mean
obviously there's some of them that just
put it into a trust for their kids and
their kids kids yeah
all that good stuff but a lot of them
also have other foundations like
i know there's a norwegian billionaire
um a hotel tycoon that was approached
and he said no
because
listen there he could be i'm not saying
he's the type of this person if you've
got
what 80 billion dollars what's his net
worth right now something ridiculous
bill gates yeah i mean i'm guessing no
no it's 130 or
is he in the 100 million 100 billion
dollar range he's number five in the
world right now so
somewhere near 100 billion all right
cool 133 billion 133 billion
do you know how many planes and boats
and yachts and
but he's just like look i just want to
help the world i like what he's doing i
like what he's doing with clean water
and sanitation in in the third world
countries i mean he's saving lives so i
respect him for that
but he also didn't build a non-profit
right so this guy has
motives that are self-serving as well so
he just i think he just got to be
cautious with his messaging but he's
also revolution
uh giving money or philanthropy
pretty much the most since you have a
rockefeller or those people as well so
he's
obviously changed it and given it the
business um aspect of
making it as efficient as possible i got
respect for bill gates so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye